okay so before you proceed I just want
to disclose that my research has been
funded by private foundations and an mah
one thing that's not there that I have
to disclose that I'm a contracted
trainer with behavioral tak and SF
mentioned I started this work at Yale
and staff was the one who started
training me in DBT you're my sensei and
it has been amazing amazing I remember
when Seth just started to train me and I
was trying to get to adherence and DBT
and that was you know taping all of my
sessions and he was looking through them
and the very first actually the second
tape that he was able to see initially
we had problems with sound and I'm
sitting down here he's telling me you
know what I have one good news and what
bad news the good news is we have sound
the bad news it's not DBT and you know
what now I agree with him because now I
understand what is involved in becoming
a DBT therapist and I of course want to
thank John Kauffman Lawrence Cahill
Heather Douglas Paula Murray who are all
here and say thank you so much for all
your support without your help and
enthusiasm for what I do it will not be
possible so of course I also want to
thank people at my new home at well
Cornell where I am under the wing of
John walk-up Donald Nathanson my
fabulous fabulous fabulous DBT therapist
and I mean walk up who is my therapist
as well she's doing treatment as usual
on the other side they actually here in
the audience they told me if I ask them
to wave they're going to be mad at me so
please wave alright yeah no I don't see
it okay so I also want to say thank you
so much for the people at green chimneys
that's one of the studies that I'm doing
with children in the residential care
and they really did not know what they
were getting themselves in when they
invited me and
hey let's build it up and it was
supposed to be a one-year study we are
year five now and I continue to tell
them that we need to change change
change and they continue to tell me yes
we do
some things are happening some things
are not but this is reality
okay I'm not attached to my slides there
are many more of them more than I can
actually cover in the talk most of them
are for your information and and of
course you can ask me whatever questions
you'd like on anything that I'm missing
and I'll be available throughout the
conference and you can also email me my
email be at the end of my slides so
we'll talk a little bit about what DBT
is all about I'll tell you how I was
able to adapt it to children and some of
the very preliminary look at what the
children look like unfortunately I don't
have the results yet
I was working feverishly one of my
studies active treatment is done but we
were not able to get the data
unfortunately in today if this
conference was tomorrow then yes but not
today
I know I'm a tease okay so DBT overview
I can't go too much detail with DBT is
all about how many of you know what DBT
is okay fantastic
all right okay so for those who don't
DBT is behavioral DBT is cognitive but
this is so much more above and beyond
that and the main thing that I want you
to remember is DBT is about balance it's
about balance between acceptance and
change and everything that we do in DBT
in so in terms of skills training or in
terms of the strategies and procedures
that therapists are involving and using
it's all either falling on the
acceptance or the change continuing why
acceptance is so important because if
you don't accept that they have a
problem there's no change one of the
examples that I really like on this
alcoholic anonymous the very first thing
that a person does is what they stand up
and they say what I'm John Doe and I am
an
thank you why is that important person
accepted I'm here because I have a
problem and therefore change is possible
people with substance use alcohol abuse
what do they say usually if they don't
haven't accepted it yet I have no
problem kidding I can quit like this
tomorrow of that you know yeah that's
not an issue for me so if there is no
acceptance what kind of change is
possible
what are we doing with that if you're
just talking about acceptance acceptance
acceptance
alright that's actually ok if you just
talk if you're just accepting if you're
just there for the client if you're just
giving you a validation and
understanding Klein is going going to
continue to come however at some point
Klein will still start experiencing high
level of arousal and sense out of
control and will feel invalidated
because yes you understand me but you
haven't helped me to resolve anything it
didn't help me to change if you just
focus on the change and tell him you
know there are some of the issues we
need to resolve them how we're going to
do it again high sense of arousal
feeling of out of control no
collaboration no learning because what
is what's going on there is that the
therapist is assuming that in validating
role of saying you have a problem you
need to change this is pretty much what
they have been hearing since they were
very little right parents telling them
you have a problem what's going on you
need to change so acceptance is
extremely extremely important not only
from the therapists clients learning to
accept themselves and accept their
issues before they can proceed to
changing them what is our main target in
DBT is of course emotion regulation and
what are the tasks we want to decrease
mood dependent behaviors we want to help
them reorient the tension and very
importantly organize their
tension in the service of their goals
now what a Murrieta was talking about in
the previous presentation she was
talking about this invalidating
environment the mothers who are having
difficulties raising their children and
they may be doing things that is not
helping the child to get you know to get
where they need to be and actually may
prevent them to get to the well-being
say that they want them to be well in
DBT we have a biosocial theory in which
we're saying you know what what it is
it's a combination between the
biological predisposition to experience
emotions in a different level the
sensitivity to the emotions the
vulnerability and it's in boring and
then the child who is that sensitive and
vulnerable is born into the environment
that cannot help and support that and it
may not necessarily be an environment
that is actually abusive or neglectful
now yes it can also happen but we're
talking about here it's a mismatch
between what the child needs and what
the parents can give they can match the
needs and I don't see it at the theory
for me this is an everyday occurrence
what I see with my clients and you know
what some of the self disclosure I have
to say is that I have two kids I have a
16 year old daughter and I have a 9 year
old son
they're diametrically opposed different
my my daughter is like a duck in the
waters everything just rolls down a
feather she's very resilient if you want
to call it that
my son he's the sensitive one he is the
one who would be like I have a cut I'm
gonna die and he actually thinks that he
actually feels it it's not dramatic if
he's not histrionic it's this is this is
the level of fear in emotion that he has
and oh boy am I happy that I was ready
to actually know what to do it was such
a sensitive child because what is going
on with children who are born sensitive
is that they indeed have very easily
activated arousal meaning that little
things for us maybe not even noticeable
activate them and they react very very
strongly somebody didn't look at me
right somebody didn't say hi
I dropped my toy in it cracked whatever
it may be and now the child will just go
pass it and not notice this chat will
have a huge outburst and it will be very
hard for that child to calm down and
sometimes we may not even understand
what's going on we may think that it
comes out from nowhere well you know
what something is going on inside that
child some thoughts them feeling some
memories something and environment make
you it boom there is an outburst so
these children go from one to hundred
pretty much in zero time a lot of the
times and this is very hard for them to
stop and then we couple it with what we
call in and validating environment and
again don't be treated by the name all
that means that again not necessarily
abuse and neglect parents don't know
what to do with these kids they feel
trapped because these kids don't come
with instructions none of them come but
these kids particularly need them and
what happens is the parent is saying oh
my god what's wrong with you why can you
just stop why are you reacting so much
to such a small thing why can't you be
just like your brother come on just stop
it just snap out of it and from all of
that what happens is chronic emotional
dysregulation one of the things that I
want to also say that that the
environmentally brain is that a lot of
the times when child is having the
outbursts the environment is not going
to respond or respond and not an in the
way that's supportive and then child
learns that you know what if I have a
vier outburst that involves me saying
I'm going to kill myself
I'm actually cutting you know what
everybody comes running so environment
can actually also support extreme
extreme expression of the emotion so
what we have out of that is an ability
to understand and label their emotions
because everybody's saying why angry not
supposed to be angry why are you feeling
angry not don't feel angry while child
is like okay I guess I'm not feeling
angry so kid is really confused now they
can of course modulate the emotional
reactions because maybe parents aren't
themselves not sensitive and they have
never learned how to deal with them then
how're they supposed to understand the
child and teach the child how to
modulate their emotions they're clueless
why BBT there's a huge amount of
empirical research right now on its
effectiveness in tackling exactly what
we need the emotional regulation and it
has been you know have such such an
incredible empirical support in the
literature for adults Alec Muller that
it's with adolescents with high degree
of success and they're all kind of
studies supporting what it's doing to
the brain activity so I'm not going to
go into that however what I want to say
is that if you're think about a
sensitive child who has what's now in
dsm-5 called disruptive mood
dysregulation disorder we'll talk about
this a little bit later in my view you
know what I would not be surprised if
research shows over time the children
with disruptive mood dysregulation
disorder some of them are on the
trajectory to have borderline
personality disorder later in life just
like children with conduct disorder and
some of them are in trajectory to
develop antisocial personality disorder
because a lot of things that we see with
children with severe sensitivity and
vulnerability is what exhibited by
patients with borderline personality
disorder in
a lot of kind of either-or thinking
suicidality self-harm behaviors extreme
expressions of emotions it's all there
so what do we do to adapt
DBT for children again you'll have a lot
of slides there that I will not cover in
detail there for your information and I
will be very very happy to answer your
questions either today or over the email
some of the things that were added to
the DBT model we needed to make sure
that children can actually understand
what emotions are we needed to make sure
that parents can understand what the
emotions are widely why we need it we
needed to understand how they start how
to do what to do with them and how
they're different from thoughts and
behaviors so we added didactic on
emotions to the individual part some of
the skills have been changed simplified
condensed and you'll see a bit later
that we even have different acronyms
here's some of the handouts stop scale
this is something that has been
developed for DBT for children to help
them stop the reactivity in the moment
the impulsive behaviors in response to
distress action marsha linehan really
liked that scale and now it is also a
part of DBT for adults so what that is
just to give you an example of how we do
it with kids stop is an acronym s stands
for stop freeze don't move a muscle if
you indeed can do that 70 percent 80
percent of the problem is solved because
you indeed were able to become aware
that you're about to react and if you
react it's not going to make it better
may actually make it worse you're
willing to actually stop meaning that
you'll be willing to do something
different about it then the rest of this
is you take a step back you detach them
from the situation a little bit you're
breathing in and out to calm down then
you're much more ready to observe what's
going on inside and out
you need information and then once you
have this information a little bit
calmer you did hatched you didn't react
now we can proceed mindfully you can ask
your wise mind what to do depending on
your goals so how do you do that you
train you practice roleplay a lot every
day instructing parents you have to do a
lot of hypothetical situations in which
the child will may be reacting and you
want to instruct him to freeze and we
give all kind of rewards at the end of
it even if it's hypothetical so the more
parents are able to roleplay
hypothetical situations the higher the
probability because it's a behavioral
rehearsal the child will actually be
able to stop and freeze in a moment when
they are to become dysregulated it's
very important practice practice
practice is boring for everybody for
children
triple importance well I'm not going to
go again in depth what we did to adapt
as I said we simplified them all four
modules are there mindfulness and
personal effectiveness emotional
regulation distress tolerance everything
is there
these acronyms are a little bit
different and more child oriented some
of the handouts on the skills opposite
action all right the three had a dragon
of chain analysis so chin analysis chain
and solution analysis and DBT is
something that is staple trying to
figure out what is it that happen and
what to do instead it's quite a
difficult thing to do with adults they
don't like doing it and sometimes it's
so toxic that therapists collude with
decline not to do chain analysis so
therapists have to be really careful to
really understand the reinforcements
that are going on the negative and the
positive they're so because their
behaviors are also being reinforced by
the client reactions well anything that
we do with kids the easiest way to teach
it through games right so this is the
game and people are asking me how did
you come up with a three-headed
drag and I said well was easy for me all
dragons in Russia have three heads
it's a Russian dragon how do use it
alright
emotion wave everything starts with
event emotions don't come about by
themselves something have to trigger
them so emotion wave is event then not
feeling interpretation of the event
because that interpretation can can can
make a difference in in terms of how you
feel about the event then the feeling
the calm brings in all kind of
sensations urges to to act such as when
you angry want to do what yell fights
grabbed by right and this is the action
urge now you don't have to do it you are
not your emotion you may actually say to
yourself you know what this what emotion
is telling me to do however in that
situation that's not going to be
effective for me to move to actually do
it what tells me to do so then you have
action whether or not you're going with
the emotion depending on the situation
the action urge and then of course the
after-effects positive negative
consequences more thoughts behaviors are
the people saying and doing things and
all of that can start all new wave and
that's very important to remember
because how long do you think one
emotion lasts one one discrete emotion
yes five seconds all right two minutes
all right so one discrete emotion lasts
about 40 seconds when I tell it to climb
they say what are you talking about I've
been mad for three weeks now even since
that happened telling me it's 40 seconds
as a yes it's 40 seconds because what
happened was you had one emotion anger
and then you spent ruminating you start
doing things that anger wants you to do
fight scream you know a little bit you
know send texts that are angry you know
whatever it is that you're doing and
that one discrete emotion turns into
what many many many many many of the
same emotion here we have a mood all
right so you know all of these things
are actually what I'm describing and
giving you sample what we talked with
children when we're doing didactics on
emotions so we're using our wave
paradigm in terms of remote how emotions
comes up when we do the Dragon game
alright
for example event a boy called me names
thought you know what
he hates me and you know what happens
people who have such strong emotions
they take their thoughts and feelings
and they take them underneath and they
actually think of them as facts that's
why you know check your facts thing and
DBT
of course feeling of anger it's a fact
he hates me now what's the urge to kick
him
what did actually happen I did kick him
and I got into detention and then you
say to the girl hey you know what I
totally understand why you would feel
angry somebody calls your name names I
would feel angry too we call it
thank you validation alright very
important staple we need to have
validation that's one of the acceptances
strategies geez did you like the outcome
the detention did you like to get into
detention
no all right so what do you want to do
with that next time somebody calls your
name what are you gonna do do you want
to think of something different yeah
then what we do we interrupt the urge
and the action by our stop skill you
have a feeling have an urge freeze don't
move a muscle
alright what I'm gonna do here and I am
going to maybe go and tell a teacher
after I stopped and freezed that's one
solution another solute and then the
after effect would be you know I would
get praised I'll feel proud of myself
you know what I'm the boss of myself
that's one of the goals that we have for
these kids to be the boss of themselves
and of course they want to be proud and
when everybody proud of them now another
solution we always need a backup walk
away and what will happen is again
feeling proud of myself you know
situation did not you know at first
maybe even cut better all right so this
is pretty much the chain analysis in a
very simplistic way and you can go
higher and higher you know with with all
those cards and this is actually a game
you know it's a huge poster you know
with its magnet receptive materials so
you know the little carts were placed on
it you know will write all of this out
with the child and and then you know we
actually sometimes write it on the sheet
of paper so the children can take it
back and look at it next time do you
they need to figure out what to do okay
so some of the things that we came up
with in terms of using the skills
sometimes children would stop and freeze
and then they kind of like okay how do I
proceed mindfully what do I do they may
kind of get stuck because they're still
emotional and this is something that we
came up with was it's it's it's skills
we'll what you do is it's this actual
skills rules from some of my clients you
have a will and you you know the are
your favorite skills you put there and
you just flip the error and whatever it
ends it lands on you have to do it
simple enough and also introduces the
game in it and some fun okay so diary
card absolutely children I don't care
its diary card we need to have it and of
course I'm not expecting that the child
is going to be able to do this without a
parent we actually not expecting the
child is going to be able to do any of
this without a parent I'll talk about
this more so parents are there to help
them and what we're tracking is emotions
we're trading to sodality self-harm
we're tracking in a factory
such as oppression destructive behaviors
were tracking effective behaviors
absolutely such as ignoring walking you
or whatever it is and then we're looking
at which skills they were able to use
throughout the week Wow
parent training component well you know
what DBT is not an individual therapy
for a child absolutely not it's a family
therapy the more you do it the more I
realize that it's a family therapy
because otherwise it's like doing
couples therapy with seeing individually
separately you can do that he needs a
diet there sometimes I do child's up
assist a child separately for the
individual however a lot of the time
especially if the child is is is like 7
8 9 I do absolutely you know most of the
time have a parent in there because it's
a problem in the relationship that we
need to resolve and the parent being
there that's that's the child's world
that's where they're coming from that's
that's the environment you know the
validating or invalidating environment
that can actually support the child or
get the child in a position that they're
going to be more and more dysregulated
now keep telling my parents you know
what there are there's absolutely no way
I'm going to see that child if you don't
commit to doing it with him full force
four cardinal rules of parenting in my
mind number one they're very simple and
very hard to do number one model the
behaviors you want how you expect your
child not to scream kick and fight if
something comes up you're upset you
scream at your kid or you physically
punish them absolutely can't
and then sometimes parents are telling
me well yeah but it's so hard to ignore
them because I feel so upset when they
do this and that and I say absolutely
it's very very hard you're kidding me
I'm a parent I know what it looks like
you think I don't want to throw my kids
out of the balcony yeah sometimes they
do
it's very very hard and on the other
hand listen we're asking you
seven-year-old to learn all of these
skills so the key can be in control of
his emotions and you're telling me that
you or forty-five-year-old cannot do it
because it's hard please you have to
understand whatever behaviors you model
that's the behaviors the child is going
to do parents come in a lot of the time
with an expectation the child should be
polite should be respectful should be
following directions right away
blah blah blah and they're shocked when
I tell them absolutely not
child should not do any of that none you
reinforce it they do it you don't they
don't do it simple as that what I shoot
shoot same position in reality this is
the picture that we draw of how we want
things to be and then we impose it on
reality it ain't matching and then we
continue to pose and impose it imagine
that we're continuing to make us
ourselves very very upset and what
happens with that is that we turn pain
into suffering
what is the difference first thing that
I want to say is sometimes parents you
know coming in and say I can do it you
know this this is very hard you know
what this is is that we have a delusion
and it's truly a delusion not my words
this is marshaling hands words that we
cannot tolerate pain yes we can
pain is an integral natural part of our
lives we need to have it because if
you're sitting at the beach sipping pina
colada you're not learning anything
right it's very very important to relax
however there is no challenge that are
presented to you that you need to
overcome and solve and if you do
overcome and solve them you progress to
the next level of mastery understanding
and learning if you hide away if you run
from them if you avoid what happens is
we turn that pain into suffering
suffering is pain plus not accepting of
that pain because of that delusion that
we can't tolerate it parent who is
giving in to the child temper outbursts
in the store because they can't accept
the pain of child screaming and they and
everybody is looking at them and judging
them and thinking what a bad parent you
know you are and they said stop it -
stop it you know what that that parent
was not able to tolerate that pain in
the moment now they turned their pain
into suffering because every time child
wants that kid in the store you bet he's
gonna do it and it's going to be very
hard to extinguish one of the things we
teach a lot of the things that we're
teaching it's very important for them to
understand that they need to accept
their child as the child is there's
nothing there are no bad people a good
people we are all people that's it
parents always ask me how am able to
tolerate their children in the session
because they are bouncing of the walls
really well I have there several answers
to that the first one is that I have my
hierarchy of what I want to do you know
me having that child sit in the chair
quietly and that's my whole time spent
on getting him in that chair you know
that's not worth it I want him to learn
I want him to listen if he's bouncing
off the wall but he's answering my
questions and I know that he's
processing and understanding that's it I
don't care
number one number two I accept I accept
another judge it's a child you know he's
doing it you know because there is some
kind of a function to that behavior very
important what is the function of
behavior if you can accept child for
what they are not judge them because a
lot of the times parents are sitting
there and judging the child and judging
themselves oh my gosh is gonna think I'm
a horrible parent oh my gosh is gonna
think my child is so you know bad
behaved and and they get discombobulated
with that
and they can't tolerate it and they look
at me I'm like so relaxed and he's like
making grounds on my head and throwing
things and whatever you know it is what
it is but I'm sitting there I'm not just
staring at the wall I am figuring out
why is the child doing this and how can
I help this child do differently if you
have that bowl as opposed to continuing
to judge and like be tense about this
two different ways of handling the
situation okay
so function of the behavior is extremely
important very good example one of my
mother's five kids single parent one of
her daughters is very aggressive to the
siblings she is kicking screaming taking
their toys whatever it is well the
mother is doing whenever she is
aggressive for this you know it's for
the safety of the other kids she grabs
that child drags her to a different room
restrains her and starts telling her to
calm down well was the function of the
behavior what do you think exactly can
you imagine five kids this mom doesn't
have time for all of them you know to
the degree that they may want so this
kids you know was actually using that
behavior to get that hug to get that mom
to themselves so hypothesis you know
what maybe that's the function of the
behavior let's test it you're going to
get the child the child is going to get
exactly the same thing by you by
yourself in the room
hugging talking whatever it is for poor
social behaviors such as sharing being
nice to their to the siblings you know
talking nice that whatever it is you
know what solved I could have thrown all
kind of skills to that child walk away
when you work of you know provoked by
your sibling you know when they take
your toy breathe whatever it is I could
have reinforced every time she would go
away and it's not gonna be consistent it
would not stay it would not be
maintained or be very useful maybe
sometimes because the function is not
solved you figure out the function
figure out how to solve it in a
different way you're done
a lot of what we're doing we're talking
about side-effects of punishments we're
talking about the dialectic of parenting
I'm not going to go into any of that it
got a taste of this here and there what
I want to make sure that that you
understand that what we do a lot of it
there's not necessarily teaching them
what to do with the behavior the change
a lot of our work is on helping the
parent accept accept the child and
accept themselves and when we talk about
the function of the behavior so that the
parents will instead of getting
discombobulated about their child being
bad they wouldn t be able to actually
figure out what the function of the
behavior is and how does how to help
that kid get that function and just just
the other day oh my god it's a great
story just the other day I have this
nine-year-old who is sitting there and
he thinks that his mother hates him and
you know what his mom doesn't hate him
but that's exactly what she exhibits
with the way she talks to him with the
way she screams at him with the way she
is comparing him to siblings and so
forth so on and this nine-year-old is
sitting there and you know I'm talking
to him saying you know what you must be
feeling very sad thinking that your mom
hates me and this nine-year-old looks at
me and he's saying I'm not sad I am
ashamed I Nero who's ashamed of himself
on that level he can actually understand
and verbalize it ashamed that he's not
good enough because he's continually
getting that message being screamed at
being told what I'm doing is wrong what
I'm feeling is wrong what I'm thinking
is wrong everybody else around me or
better I cannot control myself what are
they supposed to think about themselves
absolutely that deep deep shame and you
know what comes from deep shame one of
the functions of the behavior that we're
seeing Chuck who's miserable wouldn't
want to make the parent miserable one of
the functions
when you understand that you first need
to start repairing the relationship you
can teach skills and blah blah blah you
don't know you have to step back and say
okay I need to repair their relationship
in a way that's going to actually be
helpful in and support all of the what
we're going to be doing in top of it we
want the child to actually want to be
reinforced by the parent on the child to
be around the parent on the child to
look up to the parent and want to please
them as opposed to make them miserable
if we have that excellent we can really
capitalize on that that's why I continue
to tell parents the cardinal rules of
parenting model all the behaviors you
want number one number two if you don't
like the behavior how whatever it is
name-calling swearing whatever it is as
soon as it's not safe it's not as soon
as it does not have any problems with
safety to the child or somebody else or
property ignore ignore ignore very hard
to do well you know what you have all
those skills you know use your skills
even or you like the behavior reinforce
it parents don't do it you know a lot of
the times their attention is actually
dragged to the negative because this is
very very understandable our emotion
mind somebody is screaming you we turn
to that and we actually want to do
something about it you know how many
times do you have you seen children
sitting on the floor playing together
nicely
pairing coming in and saying oh my god
guys I'm so happy playing so nicely
together great job I'm gonna get you
cookies and milk and whatever you know
get some quiet okay I'm going to go
so as soon as gets up squabbling what
happens what's going on here why did you
do that what did you say there's so much
attention paid what do you want one of
the functions of the behavior kids got
reinforced by attention by doing for
doing what they're doing they're not
manipulative they're not pushing buttons
they behavior that we enforced because
that's that's how they know how to get
what they want they have a temper
tantrum parent can take it because
apparently we cannot tolerate pain right
and then they give them whatever the
chat once boom child learned all right
that's what I need to do next time so
what does the parent want okay so we
have model the behavior you want
reinforce what you like every little
thing because the reinforcement doesn't
happen because of the shoots why should
it be reinforcing my child for being
polite
he should be that or being respectful he
should be that or for following
directions he should do that right no he
should do nothing and the fourth one is
play with the kids have fun with them if
you have a child who actually enjoys
your company how much more reinforcing
your praise is going to be how much
actually he'll be looking up to and want
to spend time with you and would want to
make you feel proud and happy instead of
miserable so you think I want to come
home after a whole day of clients
bouncing off the wall and playing nerf
gun with my nine-year-old running around
the house shooting no or watch anime
with my daughter on YouTube oh my god
stare me
it's what I do because that's what they
like and I want to share in that and
they look and they're waiting for me to
come home because I'm the one who's
actually taking their interests
seriously and you know what I have very
very very minimal problems my kids my
daughter only had three temper outbursts
in her entire life she was three she
knew how to execute them perfectly
I am NOT a germaphobe however I actually
don't like when my three-year-old is on
the floor in a shopping mall doing this
and I have to stand not look the three
monkeys
you can look can hear can talk perfect
image of a chlorine stand there and
think oh my god what kind of bubonic
plague she's gonna bring and I have to
take her to the emergency room right now
after this so but I was able to tolerate
that and then BOOM after three times
trying she learned yeah mom ain't
budging so that's what we're hopefully
going to instill in our parents but to
do any of that they need to first accept
and let go and see their children for
what they are human beings with
behaviors that I learned and the
learning is there and we need to help
them to learn something different to get
to their goals alright I'm not going to
go through the slides how much more time
do I have to go oh my gosh
alright current research on DBT this is
my wonderful outpatient research team
Donald Nathanson wave ha
Amy Caitlyn and me over there oh did the
dragon remember we talked about the
dragon alright so this research is with
children with disruptive mood
dysregulation disorder very neat
clear-cut study only kids with dmdd
what's the MDD
multiple at least three behavioral
outbursts that are not in proportion to
the situation he didn't look at me right
I have a temper outburst for an hour or
my client yesterday she got a portion of
ice cream that was smaller that she
wanted she had an outburst I think for
five or six hours with kicking the car
kicking the mom running into the streets
you know the whole gamut of things and
in between of the of the outbursts the
child exhibits irritable angry mood so I
just want to make sure that we
understand these are not kind of kids
it's a completely different breed of
kids they're sensitive kids they are not
the one who are aggressive and they're
and they are proactive they're not the
predatory type there are conduct
disorder they are reactive type they are
reactive time because emotions feel
different to them we may not be able to
appreciate what emotions feel to them
because if what we experience emotions
from one maybe to five they go straight
to ten it's so overwhelming it's almost
toxic they can't contain it it spells
out okay so this study 44 kids oh my god
as Donald's how we got there it's all
him all him or him thank you so much and
22 in each condition its DBT for
children versus treatment as usual
whatever is usually right now delivered
at Cornell and my studies we're just
starting to do DBT with kids so the
studies that I'm doing are going to
stage one visibility and maybe some
preliminary efficacy but what we want to
see is can we do it with pre-adolescent
kids can they understand it can they use
it can their parents do it can we do it
in the format that we're doing it
because it's a little bit different from
the usual the format is so this is this
is the inclusion criteria and the format
is in a way that we need to do sessions
with the child and the parent in it
we can't have child coming in by
themselves we absolutely need to have a
parent component in it because the
parent needs to learn then we want
everything that I said about you know
their their own reactions to the kid and
how to modify they also need to learn
what the skills are so that they can
model them themselves they can prompt
the use of skills from the child they
can coach the child and the use of
skills so they have to be there 100% and
the way we did it is that everything
that we're teaching the adaptability to
the child will be that skills be the
dialectic of emotions parent are
absolutely have to be there also parents
receiving their separate training in
behavior modification techniques and
validation techniques and ID and the DAC
takes on what is the dialectics on
parenting and they're receiving skills
training together so session in the
outpatient looks like they're well again
you know it's a function of a form in
DBT nothing in seven stone 30 minutes
with the child 20 minutes with the
parent 40 minutes with skills and then
you mix and match whatever you need to
do okay the other challenge was skills
training the skills training in DBT for
adults and adolescents is groups you
know what put in a group seven-year-old
with a 13 year old what are you gonna
get and parents on top of it nobody's
getting anything right you really need
to be very careful because the
developmental levels the cognitive
levels are so different you really have
to understand your population and really
have to do it on the individual basis
that's why the skills training is in
there you know within the individual
therapy
well this child is not just behaving
that way at home schools are also a big
part of this remember team DD is at
least two settings so we'll always have
something else going on outside the
house and you know we always have to
figure out how to approach the schools
and do programs in the school settings
and that's actually quite challenging on
some levels and on some levels it's very
rewarding because you can see how the
teachers are starting to understand the
concept that we're teaching and some of
the teachers are telling me you know
what I use this on all the kids down
this is fantastic thank you so much for
teaching me this okay so DBT for kids is
a twenty six sessions but again sessions
with its topics you can deliver them so
far in 32 week format whichever way you
want it
treatments usual is pretty much exactly
the same 26 sessions but they can go all
the way to 32 weeks and then we have
three months follow up with some booster
sessions in between one two booster
sessions per month and this is clinical
side this is well Crennel and your
Presbyterian okay so what outlook kids
look like we have pretty good split
between merino males and females
most of them Caucasian hiya CS a lot of
parents are reporting a psychopathology
themselves high education no high level
of education in the family and third of
them actually got parenting training
which I don't know what kind of parents
were training it was because most of
them coming in and telling me yeah I'm
doing pain point chart but it ain't
working because there ain't doing it
right this is what they are look like in
terms of diagnosis we have a lot of ADHD
actually lower than I would
then I would be expecting but pretty
much their anxiety disorders interesting
you see we in our samples you know as
opposed to what literature shows we did
not have anybody with diagnosed
depressive disorder outside of the dmdd
and which is absolutely understandable
none of them are also also diagnosed
with conduct disorder which actually can
as per the diagnostic manual you can
have a disco morbidity but in my mind
there are like two things on the
opposite extremes you know reactive and
proactive aggression
and you know a lot of them had multiple
diagnoses actually half of them now when
I talked to you program officers in
Grand you know NIH whatever it is they
keep asking me so why did you need to do
DBT this is so big and it's like you
know so complicated do the excuse
actually need it are you kidding me and
I was and I say seven-year-old more than
50% suicidality and Cellcom
seven-year-old 8 year old nine year old
you know where they're going with that
trajectory yeah we need this all right
what was interesting when we're starting
assessing those kids this something that
we haven't been starting to do at the
very beginning of the study but we added
that measure because parents were
telling us our child has sensory
processing issues with sounds taste
touch either than with their siblings
and when we actually incorporated into
it into the assessment we saw that yeah
you know T scores this is the kind of
like a 70 and above his severe problem
and some problems you know up to 70 so a
lot of them are either some problems in
sensory processing or definite
dysfunction in sensory processing
meaning that there's something in the
brain the sensitivity is spread out its
physical sensitivity and emotional
sensitive it's very very interesting I
was very excited about that yep they all
have definitely serious you know you
know issues with functioning on the sea
gas a lot of them had previous
outpatient therapy some had
hospitalizations and almost half of them
have special services at school like
one-on-one people who are following them
around or special schools or whatever it
is because it's very very hard to
maintain them in the community now they
are on medication yep and a lot of them
are actually on stimulants with in
Sanibel you know ADHD and here's the
breakdown so some of them actually more
than one or two meds okay DBT C for
children in residential care so this is
my crew in green chimneys residential
care fantastic
fabulous therapist I loved working with
them they were so hungry because they
were feeling overwhelmed didn't know
what to do with these kids imagine and
they really jumped in with both feet and
eat it up so there we have 47 cases 27
DBT and 20 in treatment as usual and our
inclusion cream this is a much messier
study remember that one dmdd very
clear-cut this is pretty much everybody
unless they have mental retardation and
well look at that we have very low
threshold what we call mental
retardation so a lot of them have
cognitive problems unless they have P D
D or psychosis or bipolar they're in so
we have a lot of variability there so I
I don't know what that data is going to
look like and again our main issue was
to figure out can we do it can we build
a program like that in residential care
for children well will they be coming
will they be accepting and then the
second question is you know what the
benefits are okay so it's pretty much
very similar 26 individuals to 26 skills
training session now remember DBT
function of a form here we can actually
do group trainings and skills because
these children are by units by H so we
have lots of 7 8 year-olds in one unit
and you know so forth so we can actually
do it it's programmatically possible
infeasible to do group you know skills
training with kids now when I moved into
that doing the study in residential care
at Green chimneys I moved in very
opportune time because at that point
they were constructing new dorms and I
was actually able to randomize kids
TBT dorm GU door separate staff separate
therapists fantastic because otherwise
what are you gonna do put a dot on the
child's head and said you treat that one
with the dot this way and without it the
other way not possible it's a very rare
opportunity I'm very very grateful to
Green Teams to inviting me and actually
long need to do this now you know this
is a treatment as usual that they're
doing now some of the challenges there
is
they're there for two more years
you know they continue to you know have
the same DBT group all over and over
again and some of them don't need it
anymore so what do you do well we
actually do a levels of groups so new
comers at least you need to have at
least two rounds of DBT so it's full
year of DBT and then if they actually
did that they either go to pre graduate
the Graduate pre-graduate children
completed all of that two rounds of DBT
skills training however they still
continue to struggle to implement it
then we're doing pretty graduate when
it's DBT heavy with an application
actual application to the dorm in their
lives and then the graduate group it's
talking about this church and talking
about you know real live DBT in real
life what would they need to do how
would they need to use those skills
outside of the program the other one was
reinforcement ah just like with parents
punishment something that's heavily done
reinforcement it's not that much done so
there was no programmatic ways of
reinforcing that was systematic the kids
so we implemented stamping charts kids
could be getting all kind of rewards for
doing these skills for doing effective
behaviors and they loved it and also
acknowledgment of some of the children
who are doing better in DBT program and
we had a rising star which would be a
child who did so much significantly
better than you know from before or
shining sorry this is the child who just
success in DBT and we also have graduate
group shoutout they know those that our
graduate who actually helped with
running DBT groups in the first level
and kids love when other kids come in
and teach and actually talk about their
experiences I had one kid who really did
not want to engage who really had
difficulty engaging he was saying DBT
sucks
don't even say DBT skills I'm not
talking about the CBT and then over time
when he was about to get this church you
know this child is that mom one of my
therapist is saying this child is
sitting in a group and somebody else
complaining the DBT sucks and he's like
DBT is the best thing in the world
everybody have to learn dbt kidding me
so you know you can actually get a shift
that was like poster child for DBT and I
wish I cannot have his photo saying DBT
is okay okay so also mail you
communication there was a big disconnect
between milieu this is the staff on the
floor and therapists and all of that and
we needed to get them together and
discussing and making sure that they all
on the same page what is it that we're
doing milieu was also not trained I
that's this something that I continue to
struggle with and understand it's real
life and having I'm accepting it but I'm
having a hard time understanding how we
can actually solve that effectively very
fast in my mind if you're not training
behavior modification technique you can
not even look at a child in the
professional capacity wouldn't you agree
right Oh none of them are they have no
idea what's reinforcement punishment
extinction or whatever else is they
don't know any of that how come you're
doing an impression capacity you don't
know they'll say your tools of the trade
kidding me all right so I had to Train
everybody everybody got trained and
actually I also had to train Johnson
stuff nursing intervention is because
what happens a lot is Chad is cutting
they go to nursing and nurses is like oh
you poor thing what happened to you oh
oh got a boo-boo okay though lay down
watch TV I'm gonna bring you dinner you
know what I'll be cutting all the time
okay
so this is how our sample looks like ah
we only had boys because there was not a
lot of girls to randomize and okay so
here we have a bit of a different
numbers we have a lot of things going on
you can understand those are the kids
that cannot be managed at home we have
ADHD disruptive behavior which huge
amount of numbers a lot of them more
have like more than sixty percent three
or more diagnoses and the few know full
scale IQ you know not too high a lot of
them have suicidal ideation and behavior
huge amount of them psychiatric
hospitalization a lot of them have been
hospitalized four more times they start
as young as seven and you know pretty
much most of them had previous
outpatient
and setting his young as five okay a lot
of them are on all kind of medications
and thank you so much thank you so much
Francesca question is how do you help
kids differentiate what are real dangers
from their emotional reactivity how
children differentiate or don't help
them tell the difference between whether
they're reacting to a real danger versus
their having an emotional reactivity to
something that may not be a real danger
when you use that stop yes very good
question so check the fact is this
something that's real is the line
charging it use about to eat you you
have fear yeah don't stop and freeze and
think okay what am I going to do is
right now no no run however if there's a
line that's in a cage and you still have
phobia you know I have have still fear
now your fear is not justified you have
to stay there and expose right so you
teach them to differentiate especially
with children you need to have to be
very concrete and does that influence
the fight-or-flight response what does
this why you Reese when you when you
teach them to freeze does that influence
their fight-or-flight response
okay so freeze itself I don't think it
influences the the it influences the
reactivity right so they stop themselves
from reacting fight and flight response
you know as far as I understand a
sympathetic nervous system we have a lot
of skills that are getting you know
getting the parasympathetic nervous
system to get activated what is this you
know sympathetic is our fight-or-flight
parasympathetic is the one in which you
actually you know rest and digest there
are lots of skill that we're teaching
them that will activate parasympathetic
nervous system meaning that they arousal
will come down and they'll be able to
think straight ER and be able to arrive
at a solution as opposed to when they're
discombobulated so I'm not sure if I
answer that one
you know I I think that's helpful we
have a couple of questions related to
motivation and and getting kids to
commit without eliciting defensiveness
or them being resistant oh oh great
great great okay
so Marsha Linehan originally was telling
everybody that everybody has to do you
know be the other lessons whatever it is
everybody has to do the skills that
she's doing that she presented in a way
that she's doing them the teacher knows
can be different and then she turned and
said Francesca that doesn't apply to you
because she understands we're talking
with kit we're talking about kids here
and again I forgot about the question it
was about dealing with resistance that
might arise when you introduce problems
and try to get motivations yeah I don't
know why I got Marsha Linehan in there
okay so and okay I lost my train of
thought resistance the motivation oh and
the other thing that she told me that
everybody has to commit in DBT except
for what I do because some kids coming
in that you know kicking and screaming
don't want to be there in rally but they
do we don't elicit commitment from kids
if we see that the child is not going to
make we just we just forget about it we
need the commitment from the parent okay
all right how young an age do you
suggest
ignoring the behavior thinking of babies
infants as long as it's not a safety
issue
how young would you ignore as do not
reinforce oh I ignore my all the time
from very very as as soon as as soon as
they were able to focus on me which
probably will be different for Marietta
what would actually suggest but really
with my kids especially with my son you
know something is going on he is
discombobulated he's running he's like
he knows the drill okay mom come great
job coming down get what happened
alright now he's able to understand and
connect you know I need to become my mom
is long even going to give me attention
if I'm upset so as early as
I wouldn't know one-and-a-half I guess
yeah again just come not know research
support can you please explain the
difference between acceptance versus
overindulgence when responding to temper
tantrums Oh acceptance does not mean no
change acceptance means that I'm
accepting that my child is having a
tantrum tent tent a temper tantrum
however I am in no way going to give it
attention that's the change so there is
absolutely no indulgence in terms of the
temper tantrum there is a flexibility in
built-in if child is crying because you
know somebody didn't look at him right
you know that's one thing you ignore
that if child fell and scraped his knee
in crying yes absolutely going to come
there in a tent there is you know parent
have to differentiate between is this
something that's temper outbursts is or
my child in the real danger or my child
actually needs my support has nothing to
do with attention-seeking we have number
of questions about the diagnosis I think
the dmdd and his questions about is this
also apply to kids who have more
internalized instead of having temper
tantrums how do you what about childhood
bipolar how do you tell the difference
between that okay right so no in order
for a child to be diagnosed with dmdd
you know there's no in there is some
internalizing but you know in terms of
some of the feelings that are having
kind of suppressing some of the things
but it's more of externalizing you know
the behaviors that they have because
this behaviors come from them not being
able to regulate themselves so no it's
not internalizing kids now in terms of
difference between dmdd and pop bipolar
disorders so in the night is there was
this push to actually classify children
that are now called dmdd as bipolar
however people were able to recognize
that this is a constant chronic thing
the the eruptions it's not something
that's intermittent that would be
actually characteristic of a bipolar and
would you speak to
what you're suggesting the DBT for
children to children who maybe don't
have the Tantrums but their their
internalized they don't have they have
other mood problems right right
absolutely
well there's research done right now
with Tim in the England what's his name
just escaped from the one who was you
know who actually have Tom Lee Tim Lynch
thank you Tim Lynch is doing
internalizing DBT with internalizing yes
with adults absolutely right I haven't
personally done it right this is
something to look at well let me first
see what Tim Lynch was able to do with
internalizing and then I will figure out
what to do with myself well some of them
are bipolar some of them deem DD it all
depends on is a chronic or is an
intermittent well the only well how to
say usually we don't diagnose children
as having a personality disorder where
you can't absolutely diagnose a child
with personality sort of unless it's a
social percentage so which you cannot
until they're 18 however is it really a
personality disorder or a lot of it is a
learned behavior in my mind a lot of
this is a learned behavior what's there
is not a personality to sort of per se
this is a disorder of emotional
regulation that's built in this is
something that they're born with yes
they may be on the trajectory to develop
borderline personality disorder given
their symptoms however I would not start
there perhaps on that same vein there's
a question here speaking to the
neuroscience that you refer to and would
it make more sense to call this a brain
disorder is the possibility that DMD
would also become state
what what's what's not a brain disorder
not really you know one of the research
that's going on right now that I'm
really excited about you know it's not
published yet kind of like trickle for
the grapevine
researchers at Harvard Harvard took
several you know I think like 12
whatever volunteers and they have them
do mindfulness practices for 20 minutes
a day for about 20 day 12 days and they
took MRI before and after and what they
were able to find mind-boggling number
one they were able to find that there is
a increase in the gray matter in areas
that are tension concentration problem
solving memory after 20 minutes of
mindfulness for 12 days and but I could
predict that but I wasn't able to
predict was that there is shrinking in
the area that's fight and flight
syndrome as fighting flight so meaning
that this the fight and flight is
shrinking
the other one is expanding so you'll be
able to regulate more and more
effectively so yeah here we go
this is getting to some of the
understanding and reinforcement we have
the tantrum is lying on the floor face
down what is that and what to do we're
thinking about a three-year-old it's
exactly the same thing ignore ignore
ignore
now acceptance validation all that stuff
comes up either before temper outbursts
when you just catching the child may be
getting into that emotion mind and you
catch him right before and say Johnny I
totally get it
what just happened oh my gosh I got
upset too okay can we now breathe
together let's just calm down and then
you cut it right then and there or after
the tantrum is over child is the more or
less normal mood then you process again
starting with validation I told and said
what happened you were feeling this
because of that now the outcome did you
like it no what can we do next time
differently and then
you bowl plate don't just leave the
child hanging there role play role play
role play give actual points rewards
whatever it is because you need to have
behavioral rehearsal in it but one child
is on the floor facedown tantrum in
there - for God there's no way you can
actually do anything and he's gonna hear
you and understand and process it and
actually do something different
plus you're going to give it attention
so it's not effective and actually can
reinforce the tantrum thank you so much